bien on va rester avec nous là ça dépend
pour quoi pour une jolie dernier qui
revient alors il n'y a pas à liker un
petit peu oui c'est une jolie fille
jolie fille oui ça fera quatre séverine
ferrer va serrer une brise et michèle
laroque
oui on s'est promené oui connaissent
andré santini chez le dernier
francis lalanne s'est senti ni pardon
vous souvenez petit doigt michel je la
connais et c'est pas pour dire mais
j'aime beaucoup et me dit oh là là je
suis très content de vous rencontrer
ah bon voilà tout simplement parce que
vous aimez
la parité pour cette façon je suis super
contente de vous rencontrer et c'est
sincère et je vous lis et l'ina non je
la connais pas vraiment on se croise
aussi il ya peu de temps et me servir
oui je vous connais vous je vous
raconterai tout à l'heure on me laissait
faire les choses enfin je vais mettre en
condition on note aussi un plein j'ai
demandé qu'on mette le jingle enfin
comme jingle quand vous rentriez barbie
girl parakois parce que vous êtes une
fanatique des poupées barbie
oui c'est vrai j'étais choqué en fin
d'année à new york vous avez sélectionné
vous avez combien de poupée barbie chez
vous challah les 150
quand j'étais à la réunion est
aujourd'hui me reste plus beaucoup mais
j'ai en journée quand même une
cinquantaine avec des poupées de
collection
séverine faire a déclaré barbie a
longtemps représenté la femme que je
voulais devenir lorsque j'étais enfant
dans les noirs du compte les gens me
soulier s'est fait un nom de loin dit ou
pas bon du tout enfin l ap un peu de
graisse elle est belle elle a des formes
elle est blonde ranger ta blonde en a
raté du bruit michel bronn elles sont
moins joli mais c'est pas grave je
trouve que maintenant la perfection
c'est ça ne veut plus rien dire
ah bon sauf qu'une femme est beaucoup
plus jolie avec ses défauts alors j'ai
eu une enfance entendu l'enfant sauvé
l'enfant de du bd de la liberté tout à
l'heure vous avez été enlevés très libre
aussi à la réunion très jeune vous
adoriez vous produire en spectacle
chanté dansé pour le pour le voisinage
pas forcément pour le voisinage vos
parents vous étés mini miss réunion à
sept ans j'ai des défilés déjà très très
jeune et à 8 ans effectivement vous
étiez meneuse de revue pour un spectacle
ça plaît
ne s'est peut-être pas le mot non
j'étais chorégraphe et le but est venu
d'un oued un groupe d'enfants que
j'avais créé avec ma meilleure amie qui
s'appelait le baby show et on était une
dizaine de petits de 4 à 13 ans et je
faisais des chorégraphies avec les
copines je dessine et les modèles et
c'est les mamans qui faisait les
vêtements et puis on se produisait dans
les arbres de noël dans les comités etc
et on s'amusait beaucoup on avait un
jour de leur poche en vous et tous y
avait du temps va pas d'elsa on faisait
tous les dessins animés de l'époque il y
avait du vent divin et sa part a dit joe
le taxi file plein de choses et à neuf
en fait la première comédie musicale
s'appelait chemisier rose et paniers
blanc est votre première émission de
télé à l'âge de 9 ans cinq enfants d'une
reine
la première séverine club
alors après l'âge de 14 ans le grand
moment est arrivé
vous avez rencontré patrick savatier
13 ans 13 ans à rennes je suis désolé je
peux pas en métro après 91 13 ans et en
fait on a une grande surprise parce que
mes petits camarades du baby show
m'avait fait ce cadeau tout simplement
d'écrire à sabatier et et de décines
nous faire inviter pour pour ce grand
show qui à l'époque était enfin pour
nous c'était le rêve quoi et finalement
un jour on a reçu un coup de fil à la
maison et puis j'entends voilà bon c'est
tout ça à la une puis ouais c'est ça
ouais et puis finalement je pense du
bien voilà on vous appelle de la
métropole et où je suis mais non mais
vous rigolez
ce que j'appelle papa papa papa ya un
côté celles de la métropole que
j'entendais un décalage donc tout de
suite me suis dit bon d'habitude c'est
ce que oui on ya un décalage entre les
communications parisienne et
réunionnaises et finalement il tarde et
où on a un peu discuté d'une diva
attends je crois qu'au vin je crois que
le rêve les arrivées voilà tu vas tout
ça a une
ils ont fait venir dix enfants on
n'avait jamais pris l'avion et c'était
génial parce que les mamans elles sont
venues et tout est fait mais en week end
vous avez quelque chose patrick sabatier
lendemain c'était moi j'ai médias génial
à noter on était quinze personnes mais
aucun cas faire venir boyer c'est tout à
l'âge de 15 ans vous décidez vos parents
à venir s'installer en france avant
encore mieux oui on a tout quitté là bas
et on est venu à l'arrêt enfin on est
venus de la réunion donc ma mère a tout
abandonné mon père a tout abandonné il
savait que c'était ma passion et celle
de mon petit frère aussi et c'est pour
ça que d'un merci merci merci et
aujourd'hui je suis contente parce que
bon j'ai j'ai pas réussi mais disons que
je me dis enfin j'essaye de me mettre un
schéma dans la tête tous les gens me
dire qu'il ya quarante mille marché je
viens de monter le premier publié sur la
première marche
et puis j'espère qu'ils sont contents
ils ne l'ont jamais dit mais c'est vrai
que ce n'est pas facile en arrivant à
paris et on a vécu beaucoup de galères
on n'avait pas de connexion on avait un
producteur qui s'avérait être véreux et
sans la situer bien plus tard mais bon
il fallait que je passe par là pour
aujourd'hui vivre des expériences que je
en train de vie en maintenant vous
présentez fans de le samedi matin sur m6
et vous êtes parfois très très fan
des stars de l'émission enfin la presse
people s'est fait l'écho de quelques
stars dont vous êtes devenu très fan bah
oui soir vous en photo avec un certain
nombre de deux vedettes de la chanson
dans des journaux que personne à vous
lire en général d air et c'est normal
vous les fréquentes et donc c'est normal
qu'à un moment vous tombiez oui font
partie de mon métier c'est je rencontre
au quotidien c'est pas forcément d amour
d aligre est la paix parmi tant souffert
de ça des photos dans la presse people
on vous voyez les gens les sofas
chanteur oui et je vais le faire jamais
les mêmes louis parce que heureusement
que j'ai plein de fréquentation sinon ce
serait triste et monotone comme vicieux
mais oui j'en ai souffert et un moment
j'en ai vraiment eu ras-le-bol
je vous invite à les raconter vos
malheurs au dalaï lama pas raconter mais
ils ont trouvé du réconfort auprès du
dalaï lama